it's a it's a country that's gone it's
got the highest inflation in the world
we're talking about I think I can make
up a figure it's going to be probably
true see like the last one I saw was
kinda credible with a million and a half
percent per year hello and welcome to
trigonometry I'm Frances Foster i'm
konstantine kisum and this is a show for
you if you're bored of watching people
on the internet having arguments they
know nothing about a trigonometry we
don't pretend to be the experts we ask
the experts
a brilliant guest this week is a BBC
journalist Vladimir Hernandez welcome to
trigonometry Thank You fern who doesn't
know you very quickly the question we
always ask at the beginning is who are
you what's been your journey through
life how are you where you are so of
course people a suppose will think
immediately I've got this really weird
name vladimir hernandez russian name
latin surname kind of speak english okay
so trying to figure me out is a bit
complicated so I am probably half as
well and half British in terms of places
where I lived I was born in France grew
up in Venezuela my grandparents are
Spanish I don't even know where I'm from
it's very complicated but I've been a
BBC journalist for quite a long time now
I've been covering a lot of foreign news
mostly in Latin America where that's
where my background is I know a bit
about that learns a lot about that
definitely but have been doing a lot of
foreign news since then in different
capacities reporting filming producer
and so yeah I suppose that's who I kind
of am hmm and that's what the reason we
wanted to talk to you as every viewer of
this program will know because Francis
mentioned is about five times every
episode is mother and we wanted to talk
to you about that because I think in the
mainstream public kind of perception of
Venezuela probably the last time we
heard until about Venezuela until
recently would have been you know do
Chavez Jeremy Corbyn going what a great
place when Sol is
and now the situation has got very very
bad we don't seem to hear the same
people talking about in quite the same
way so one of the things we wanted to
ask you to do is just to lay out for our
viewers and our listeners what is the
situation and how has it happened over
the last decade so you may need to
fast-forward all of this photo in a long
rant about no it's changed quite a bit
definitely I I suppose my own personal
journey kind of reflects a bit of has it
changed so from probably early 2000s I
used to go there around this time of the
year February March try to get rid of
winter went there for a month spent time
with my family and I was kind of happen
in every year I was going back on
holidays probably since 2010 I just now
only go for work because as a journalist
that's kind of when my work is doing
that in sort of conflict zones and
venison increasingly became one in in in
so many levels in the last four over
2019 last three years at least it's
become yeah unrecognizable in so many
ways I think probably it's fair to say
that at least three million people have
left the country and that we're talking
about about ten percent of the
population has left the country and
that's just fleeing on levels I've been
compared to Syria have minke about say
Yemen having to cover it compared to a
lot of conflict zones and it's just the
simple things of life that we just take
for granted everyday have most of them
just gone away and indifferent like a
food right well there was a universe so
there was a university study about it
the government is not polish in stats
for about three years now or more so we
don't have the in a normal situation you
go to government agencies or entities
and then you go to official data which
is being gathered by researchers
methodology all of that that has gone
away in Venezuela probably five years
ago so universities have tried to sort
of paint a picture of what's going on
one of the last ones that I saw which
was from 2018 was just like
mind-boggling it talked about 83% of the
population was struggling to eat two
times three times a day it talked about
how an average of Venezuelans had lost
seven kilos in in in average as a it was
about more than 90% of Venezuelan had
lost seven kilos in average I've got a
lot of my family still lived there they
don't want to go and we can talk about
why they don't want to go later but I've
seen I've seen my brothers or my mom or
my cousins lose weight and it's not too
a you know famished level of Ethiopia or
those sort of striking pictures but it
is it is really shocking when you see
people you know you don't report on
people you don't know and they become
people you leave and then you close at
all but when you also see how it's going
on people you knows yeah it's just mind
boggling but anyway it's a it's a
country that's gone it's got the highest
inflation in the world we're talking
about I think I can make up a figure
it's going to be probably true see like
the last one I saw was kind of credible
was a million and a half percent per
year and then I've heard some talk about
the IMF say and three million percent so
don't quote me IMF but it's probably
true anyway I mean the prices are not
you go to a any place where you want to
buy something you won't see the prices
on the wall you won't see a menu with
the prices because they're just changing
so fast that it's not worth even writing
them down like the whole German history
lesson where they was wheeling
wheelbarrows of cash that kind of said
well and the cash thing is incredibly
again it's it's a bizarre world
Venezuela cash is worthless I went there
two years ago thinking this this is the
lowest of the lowest and it went worse
but people were selling cash on bin bags
and it's full of cash and they would
charge you a hundred percent of what
that cash was worth because it was such
a high valued commodity that you just
couldn't get your hands on to it
you can't withdraw you have limits to
what you can get from a cash machine or
from a bank but that is probably worse
you know a bus fare so it's an
incredibly digitalized Bank in society I
a year and a half ago I was there me and
the team we were in a really really
remote area of Venezuelan air and at the
Amazon we wanted to eat something and
there was this lady who had fish in a
river she was just like literally just
fish grilled it and we were like we
would love to eat that but we just don't
have any
kasher guess no one here asked a [ __ ]
sure oh don't worry just transfer me on
my iPhone I'll just give it my bank
account and everywhere everyone's just
going on phones are going on computers
or just getting transfers electronically
so that just reflects how everything is
kind of like been turned upside down you
can't make phone calls from inside the
country outside of the country unless
it's on whatsapp or some know that you
just can use a mobile phone to call
abroad because of phone companies most
of them owed so much money that they
they stopped providing the service six
seven years ago you had direct 3040
Airlines going into Venezuela today you
probably have five six if and we haven't
even talked about in security and safety
there's a country that where thousands
of people killed every year more than
war zone levels kidnappings are just
everywhere I'm describing a picture of
help but the most bonkers things well if
you go there you will see normal life
you just see people coping you just see
people just getting on with it I'm not
quoting anyone but you just see people
just trying to adapt to normal life it's
a really it's a really really crazy
place and what is the corruption levels
like because this is something that a
lot of people in this country and you
know people on the far left don't want
to admit of the corruption with the
Chavez regime and the Maduro regime and
the I think it's some billions if not
trillions been in stolen some people so
there are several examples that will
tell you how bad it has been in terms of
corruption and I don't want to pretend
also that this is a new thing in Janice
Weller a lot of countries probably South
American Latin America have had issues
with corruption and we've seen with
Brazil the whole elaborate scandal which
is huge of massive proportions anyway in
Venezuela
during the Chavez years I think one of
them there were two things that probably
led to a it's fair to say arise a big
rise in corruption lack of
accountability the government didn't
need to create or publish anything of
how they were spending anything we we
the BBC did a program recently this year
and they had a man
run the old company for about ten years
in the program he was saying you know
Hugo Chavez came to me and he said I
want to do all these social programs and
you know you from a personal level
relate to that thing that you know all
right that's a good idea let's help some
people and this man who was running the
oil company was saying I said yeah I
definitely wanted to help him so Chavis
tells me can I have 1 billion dollars so
I can get all of that into social
programs and this man says no you can
have a hundred billion dollars to do
that and none of that was ever published
where that money went
I remember I was still in the country at
the time and I remember that fund was
created - it was a fund created with oil
money where the government would decide
how to spend it on social programs that
money wouldn't go to hospitals that
money wouldn't go to help supermarkets
that money would go went to create a
whole parallel structure of spending in
the country the first at article of that
legislation I remember it just I've seen
I've never forgotten that said President
Hugo the president of the country can
decide discretional e how does he spend
this that's it all right here you go a
hundred billion dollars I don't have to
tell anyone what I do with it the second
thing that will sort of give you an idea
of how corruption went is that money was
handed over to people who were and I
ain't not experiencing what they were
doing or B who didn't have to be
accountable about it so the the food
distribution in the country about six
seven years ago was given entirely to
the military and they were the ones who
started deciding where do i I'm given
money and how do I spend it the minister
I don't have to declare where that money
went
no one knows how that was run a lot of
companies because of price controls
because of foreign currency controls
were given licenses to get cash to
import stuff and then provide it to
government agencies none of that is
published none of that went away so how
has this happened why to me because I
think the one of the things that
troubles me with Venezuela is that is
being used at kind of as a political
football by people on all sides for
people who hate America say well it's
just American involvement American
interference American sanctions has
created this the people who hate
socialism in any form
well this is what happens every time
there's any form of socialism and but
what what is your assessment of how how
Venezuela has come to this point you
know when you hear about these stories
about when when politicians get
criticized for policies that people
would say but that's unsustainable that
will never work well that's what
happened now 1999 Hugo Chavez got
elected by vast majority of Venezuela it
was no one in the country hadn't voted
for him I didn't but there was no one in
the country who hadn't voted for him
everyone there throughout the years all
the people at least I run my social
circle around a lot of flight over like
I feel disappointed it's not going
anywhere I'm not benefiting until today
which is incredibly unpopular Hugo
Chavez when he arrived he was trying to
cleanse or provide a breath of fresh air
to a political system that was
incredibly corrupt that it was also it
didn't look at what the poor needed it
was very there was a lot of class
divides anyway so he came in sort of
empowered by by a reason he became
whether he came in with all these
policies and immediately were like well
he's going to pay for that and now we
are what is it twenty years later and
seeing the result of all those policies
in the in these twenty years of here
Chavez and Nicolas Maduro Venezuela has
gone through one of the biggest oil
incomes a country has ever seen
without trillions of dollars is the
amount of money is just insane in the
peak of that income of from oil
the government was incurring a new debt
that is that doesn't make sense yeah
you've got money you've got like cash
you've got the wealth why do you need
new debt it was because of the policy of
lets me increase the size of the state
let me create all these new universities
new hospitals new schools new programs
when there were already hospital schools
and programs that just needed money to
be developed but I'm going to create so
you had it all became political just the
university I studied in which is Central
University of Venezuela so the biggest
universities in the country underfunded
historically well did the government do
create a new university right in front
of it because it was more politically in
favor of him and they appointed their
own
authorities but but you got that there
so you created a whole new parallel
structure of the state with all this
money and then when the oil price went
down it just became unsustainable at the
year there's also the private sector
incredibly went down because of
nationalizations because it just wasn't
he's just gonna get an income anymore
there was no profit to be made it just
all became unsustainable and today Hugo
Chavez was in swimming through this
crisis through his charisma and he was
convincing people and he was you know
incredibly charming man and people would
follow him blindly nicolas maduro
probably his best qualities that he's
been a great imitator of Hugo Chavez if
anyone who speaks Spanish or is no not
speak Spanish
anyone who's brought Venezuela will have
who knew madura before Chavez died we'll
see how today he is earning his way of
speaking the way he was he talks his
tone his voice the way he acts is just
trying to imitate Hugo Chavez that's its
best rate and how much of this can be
blamed on the United States because
people on the left so you know you know
this states this is what they do this is
their modus operandi a government it
declares your country declares itself
socialist you know insidious forces come
in bring it down from the inside is this
in any way true or I don't think I think
probably a very limited amount of people
would be able to say where this is true
or not I'm definitely not one of them
yeah it's because the government's line
has been in the last don't know decade
let's say our cut our economy is
suffering because there's an economic
war against us there's an economic war
against socialism because we're
providing a socialist proposal and we
represent in something the United States
doesn't want us to have and we want to
be we're going to be crushed by impair
ISM all of that what is an economic war
measures and policies or trying to
destabilize economy via businessmen
third parties all of that that sounds
like an incredibly complex plan that I
wonder who actually if that is true who
actually knows whether that's signed
where is that written who's saying that
that's happening
the United States and South American
Latin American general have pretty
terrible history and throughout the
United States has intervened in Chile
and Guatemala and Mexico and Argentina
Chile listen anyway it could like
evidently directly in the 1970s and the
80s and 90s in Central America is the
u.s. intervening in Venezuela I think
politically they clearly did would they
must have been clearly interested from
the very beginning that they didn't
really like the way Chavez was talking
or the way he was talking about the u.s.
in particular his affiliations with Cuba
on all of that is the u.s. toplin been
trying to topple the Venezuelan
government for twenty years because it's
a socialist government I don't think so
I firstly don't think so I kind of prove
you that the United States is not doing
that but I can definitely the main
argument is this this is all happening
because we're a socialist government and
because we have one of the biggest or if
not the biggest oil reserves in the
world Bolivia has been a socialist
government for at least 15 years it's
got the biggest oil natural gas reserves
in the world has a one digit inflation
rate it's an economy that kind of is
okay it has an indigenous precedent and
it has its problems
lots of political problems but it's
there and it's been fine Argentina had
12 years of a socialist government it
has one of the biggest grain and
commodities of farming commodities in
the world has one of the beef producing
countries in the world there was 12
years of socialist government in
Argentina which got elected out and that
didn't seem to have the u.s. sort of
running it over itself to try to stop it
Brazil had don't know 12 16 years of
Lula da Silva then had Dilma and you can
probably the narrative says that Dilma
Rousseff got kicked out because the u.s.
led a coup against sort of politically
although that's probably more internal
Brazilian politics and a mess than
anything else so why why is this
fascination with Venezuela we are the
victims of it for me it's it's clearly
aware it's a blame game for an easy-out
to go to not take responsibility for the
overspending the waste the corruption
that you're talking about
and maybe four as well you know someone
who was born in the Soviet Union I
personally think that those kind of hard
hard socialist system they create the
incentives for those kind of things
because like you said there's a lack of
accountability there's a scope for
corruption there's a such fake idea that
we're all going to be equal and
everything can be fine but actually it
does create a small elite of people who
are able to seize the resources and use
them for themselves right I think that
the also the main thing for me is that
it's that lack of criticism and and and
an openness to if that doesn't work we
need to call it out you could argue that
it's socialism didn't work there I
personally don't think probably that was
ever socialist regime at all there
there's all this narrative and talk and
this course about we are socialists and
we care for the people building the
other hand I'm just getting rich here it
was a change of elite in Venezuela where
you had traditional parties and then a
new one comes in and right we just
replace the elite that was before and
now with a new elite we didn't have
anything but you have that rhetoric and
that this calls off we're doing this for
the people don't worry we've got your
back we've got your back you're still in
a slum but 20 years later don't worry we
believe in you may that that just
doesn't work that way it's that level of
if you're outside of the country and
you're thinking no this is all to blame
it's a us to blame no it can't be if
it's an economic war then you bloody
lost it for years you're not doing your
job either because you're not winning
that economic war or because you'd
basically just look in the other way
it's it's there is a lot of what about
ISM oh are you talking about me what
about those kids in Colombia who are
suffering as well well no we're talking
about in a sweater right now we're not
talking about anything else and we've
made all those government there's been a
huge amount of criticism I've got for my
family's still there I've got friends
who are still there and they talk about
secret police people disappear
journalists being intimidated could you
enlighten us a little bit as to what is
happening I think that's so you've got
the humanitarian catastrophe going on I
just can't call it another way for it
going on for a while and obviously it's
easier for media organisations to sort
of learn kind of lean that way but
underneath all of this I think it's fair
to say that in five six years
human right situation is it's terrible I
can't so let's let's call out well I
think Madara has been doing or what is
evidently been sort of explained and
showed what it is you've got people
being detained and in in in in jails a
judge issues a release order and the
secret police says well I don't care
about that I'll keep you for another
year here that's complete and non
guarantee of basic human rights you've
got people being tortured you have
people being prosecuted for political
views most one of the main problems that
Venezuela has is why are there no
elections because anyone who's a
politician of any sort and you can
criticize him on whatever you think
about their policies on all that but as
soon as any politician comes to the fore
he will be as much men most of them have
been banned for running trumped-up
charges over no he's a terrorist he's
destabilizing the regime only yesterday
I saw there was a judge who released
someone on corruption charges
the sentence it was probably a bit wrong
but there was more about her political
affiliations against the government
everyone has the right for a political
view she was yesterday sentenced to five
years in jail because it was a what's
the word it was it was I was like
spiritual treason to the country what
does that even mean but you get all I
think the judiciary a minister and the
way it has worked it's incredibly
unreliable and has led to a series of
human rights violations which are
terrible we did an investigation in the
last year and we just showed the inside
of what the secret police main
headquarters is looking like and it's
horrible I mean we're talking about
tortures of all sorts of scales we're
talking about people being detained
without reason we're talking about
people's I'm not going to go into porn
morbid details about pretty nasty stuff
and on the other hand there is an
apparatus of people who have been armed
and supported politically by the
government which are militias
effectively called colectivos which is
effectively the armed wing of the
government which is they're not
affiliated with me but they're all where
government shirts and any time there's a
protest there are some dissidents these
guys just come in and just write no more
protests in
only this year there was quite a bit of
unrest and in the hills and the slums in
Caracas in particular a lot of people
came down to the city assorted chanting
and voicing their discontent etc some of
them might know for a fact I know in
particular one it's a big one there's a
place called in Caracas Patera it's a
slum of about a million and a half
people it's a big place one of the areas
there was completely taken over by a
special force of the police
some people are said to have been killed
and they just camp there for several
days to stop people from going out I I'm
always reluctant to talk about what
journalists go through because know
about journalism and a lot of
journalists just pick themselves up too
much frankly I do think you should talk
about it because I think how journalists
are treated is a very good reflection of
what is happening in a country because
you know Russia has a terrible problem
with journalists and if that tells you
everything about freedom of speech
it tells you everything about how the
regime maintains itself it tells you
quite a lot so it's not necessarily
about feeling sorry for poor Vladimir
but I think it's reflective of what's
happening in society so do tell us so
people I've worked with I don't know I
know someone who flew a drone over a
protester because he wanted to get some
really nice shots although good protest
you know later in the day secret police
came to his house took him away he was
eight months in prison without charge
without a judge saying anything without
a sentence and as as he was picked up he
was released eight months later
that's knows no rule of law I know
people who have been foreign nationals
who have been in Venezuela they've been
covering the crisis and they get their
ported I've know people have been barred
from entering the country
I know journalists who have been picked
up randomly and then they just get put
away for some time and then released
it's not an easy place to work and this
is the purpose of all of this is to
prevent people from speaking out against
what the regime is doing I think I think
the purpose of this is just to try and
I'm going to quote a security guard one
of these security police officers who we
spoke to recently and he was just saying
the purpose of this is just to maintain
fear on what you're doing to keep you
fearful of anything you're doing that it
may have consequences to try to preempt
any further digging you would like
a lot of the narrative that you will
hear outside of Venezuela is the media
events all these lies there isn't media
in Venezuela they used to be 15 years
ago probably for big private television
channels none of those they are still
there but all of them were bought by
third-party government-affiliated
supporters yeah there are no independent
television channels exactly like Russia
when you have protests there are you
don't see them on any television screen
when they're really so people inside the
country don't know that the protests
opening through the media know that
there's none of that there error
probably I'll tell you about the the
capital at least there are one or two
radio stations who may broadcast about
it that in a very limited way and
sometimes it often happens as soon as
those approaches and people are in the
radios are broadcasting about it then
the government calls in a speech
donation and then everyone has to
transmit that by law so that the
airwaves are completely blocked and you
have to listen to what Maduro has to say
there is a big presence of the state TV
everywhere and they broadcast a view of
the world whenever there was some kind
of crisis or a big demonstration they
would place one lake yeah on TV yes one
lake was playing you knew something yeah
where do people get their sorry in
France what do people get their
information is social media that's
that's horrible because they're showing
me just like a horrible place no you can
get whatever there and there's an what's
up you can get a lot of things which are
not true you can get a lot of things
which are but that's the only place
where people are actually following
what's going on I don't want to cleanse
the reputation of fried media Minnesota
historically at all there have been
moments where yeah they haven't frankly
haven't covered ourselves in glory but
at this point I just find it that it's
astonishing to think about the media
created all of this when there isn't
media in Venezuela and there's this
image of Chavez of being a socialist
hero as it were one of my relatives is
very high up in the Chavez government
and Chavez asked him to transfer some
money from the bank of Venezuela to his
private funds my and my relative refused
to do
he got fired on national TV well yeah
and then I was put under house arrest
until he changed his mind that's amazing
there's so much yeah exactly that's so
that's the other thing and and you can
probably probably people who are looking
at what Trump's doing right now that's a
good way of understanding what Travis
used to be yeah
Chavez wouldn't be as prominent on
Twitter but he would be you see Trump
right now calling out journalists and
rallies when he doesn't like them so no
CNN and that's journalists over there
yeah enemy of the people
that's what ciao is used to do just that
probably in the United States you get
roughed up a bit some journalists have
been beaten up and when it's well know
that led to consequences people got
really nasty ly attacked and there was
some consequences to that or you had the
security services changing and sort of
chasing them and doing all sorts of
things like I think probably Travis is
sort of track record on that it's it's
cleaner despite having cases like that I
know a lot of people you know this we're
talking about a precedent here
charismatic leader all you want but he
will walk down squares have it live
broadcast on state TV and say right who
owns that shop over there X or Y okay
well let's nationalize that let's
nationalize that and that and that and
that's it and that's that's in a way how
he run the country which is probably
again unsustainable that's where we are
now and what do you make of the Western
politicians and the way the conversation
is conducted I brought up kind of Jeremy
Corbyn talking about positively about
the case in Venice all we don't hear so
much of that anymore do we
no I think a lot of times when the US
gets involved you see a lot of people in
Minnesota saying please stop don't talk
anymore you just there's a lot of noise
you creating a narrative you just
reinforcing the stereotype stereotype
it's a USS fault as the u.s. involved as
all of that I think there's been a big
shift right now in narrative because a
lot of governments have there's a lot of
governments especially in South America
who were not friends of Hugo Chavez or
the Beneful and government at all and
you have people from the very far right
like Brazil in balls and arrow and you
have other people in dinner in Chile or
were in other countries but there are a
lot of people calling it out but those
who are of the Jeremy Corbyn Malden as
in historical left lead left-leaning
etc like for instance the President of
Mexico very popular guy got elected
longstanding left politician left-wing
politician he's not calling out what's
going on in Venezuela at all he's
standing on the fence of his owners for
Venezuelan to the side I think from an
outsider's perspective and I'll tell you
more about whether diaspora is talking
about there's a lot of frustration about
that because I think there's a
responsibility for people to call it off
it doesn't work and when people tell you
especially you see narratives in the US
or here in the UK about that is not a
dictatorship well I'd just refer you
back to those people being killed
legally there's people being tortured
people being illegally arrested that
sounds like a dictatorship frankly I was
very I'm four years was very reluctant
to call it a dictatorship it seemed more
a totalitarian government but as soon as
you start crossing those lines of human
right basic rights where you're not you
controlling the system to not allow
people to feed themselves you're
torturing people you're arresting people
sorry that's that you've just crossed a
big line there and Quan wydo
who is it's very complex I mean
Venezuelan politics is incredibly
complicated and even if you're if you're
in an exponent it still doesn't seem to
make sense what is a situation with him
because he prison and late is he right
I've got another I've got another oh I
think a mistake would be calling him a
self-proclaimed president of a country I
think that's what creeped in a lot at
the beginning this is not a chap who
stood up on the street and said I'm the
president follow me
bear with me
Maduro got reelected in his words two
years ago it was an election which had a
huge high abstention rate the company
that ran the software for the electronic
vote fled the country and said there was
a lot of millions of votes had been
tampered with and they couldn't account
for the relative reliability of that
election despite that he swore himself
in as the president so that was an
election with serious doubts about
electron
vote and no international observers you
will hear oh but there were
international observers no there were no
official international observers there
were people invited by the government
ask international so is a big difference
there one of those I know the case very
closely Palestinian man comes in to
Venezuela he on the side he had some
contracts with the Venezuelan government
for imports and exports which is all
fine that's listen talk about his
business that's all that's his business
and the governments but he was not an
international observer he came into that
country partially brought in by a
government democratic credentials of
Nicolas Maduro went downhill after that
so he comes so he came in this year to
swear himself in as a new president of
the country new term but you were not
elected or that doesn't seem legit the
Constitution the legal framework says if
there is a vacuum of power it's a head
of the National Assembly who should
assume it by the time Nicolas Maduro its
terms expired on January this year
vacuum of power begins one word or comes
and says I'm the head of the National
Assembly I should be temporarily ruling
the country until we can call for
elections and that's his main argument
[Music]
we've talked about and finished early
obviously a very serious subject let's
lighten it up and we want to Mexico
let's talk about chopped up head we do I
mean normally we try to keep it very
light-hearted but some of the stuff that
we're talking about is very very very
serious yeah and the reason I wanted to
ask about Mexico is we've had a couple
of guests on recently to talk about
drugs and the drug war and and the
consequences of that and I think one of
the the sides of it often gets ignored
when we talk about drug
decriminalization or no we must we must
make sure that people don't take drugs
as we forget the downstream consequences
of it and I think nowhere is that more
evident than what's happening in Mexico
right because you've done some work in
your country when you mean downstream
you mean like what's coming from the
u.s. back into Mexico no I mean in the
production chain like what our demand
for drugs in the West creates in the
third world essentially in Latin America
and places where it's produced where
it's traffic etc so I suppose one of the
main sort of issues about the whole drug
trafficking world is where that where
all of that is going to so you've got
all these people in Bolivia and Peru
producing tons and tons of cocaine let's
say every year but that is only going to
a marker those asking for it those
chicken-and-egg but still both of them
probably at fault i think one of the
things that you'll find in mexico spoken
about a lot is that there isn't the same
scrutiny over there is a big scrutiny
over drug trafficking cartels glorifying
all these people who are like yeah or
these charismatic leaders that you see
them on netflix afterwards but no one's
talking about this huge flow of guns
from the u.s. back into Mexico I know
for the story going around which is
fascinating about Mexico really only has
one place that sells guns legally in the
country and we're talking about a
country of 5060 million people most of
the guns that drug traffickers then use
or criminal gangs use are coming from
the US and there is this huge trade in
between ilex ng drugs you send me back
guns because of course in the u.s. we
all know that buying guns is quite
simple
and and then you have that sort of third
sort of strand of yes should we legalize
all of this and get rid of it I think
that's too much of an ass clinic in a
country in a country and in a region
really that is incredibly conservative
about drug use and in general but I
don't mean in Mexico I don't I don't
think I actually don't know that
legalizing drugs in Mexico would make a
big difference I'm talking about the US
the UK Western Europe where that a lot
of that demand is coming from for and do
you think that the situation we'll see
now in Mexico is a consequence of the
drug war the war on drugs rather III
disagree with both war on drugs the
drugs at war because it's just it's a
it's a very unknown again it's not it's
just a personal view it's not it's a
very simplified way of that this is not
just these bad guys who are trafficking
drugs it's a very deep structural
problem in that in society there where
you have demand on one side that
no-one's looking at you've got the
government structures in all of the
countries that produce and not only in
Latin America and Afghanistan and all
sorts of Thailand of Malaysia which are
convenient to this which have agreements
with this and frankly without trying to
sound to conspiracy theory about it if
you look at all the story about the DEA
and Mexico in the last 20 years or
there's a lot of things that looks more
for a film than for a reality but a lot
of it is reality what do you mean
because we might not be familiar with
that stuff about if you look at the
Central American conflict where the US
was funding paramilitary groups is all
out in the open I'm not making this up
the US government was funding
paramilitary groups tried to destabilize
Nicaragua what's a mile and Salvador
their militias left-wing militias
they're the money used to buy those
weapons came from the dirt cartels so
there was there's all these reports and
books being written about frankly the
DEA was just working with the drug
cartels to give money to these people so
they can maintain their political views
intact and it was all called war etc etc
is the DEA is the DEA let me say that in
a more clear way there are a lot of
books being written about how the DEA is
as responsible for creating all the drug
cartels that we know of today
well those let us that's where they come
from right
were trained by the Americans in order
to fight the drug war supposedly they
all came back they all defected they all
became this new cartel right yes at the
beginning of the Setters which I'm not
clear anymore how big it still is but it
used to be some years ago one of the
biggest and most sort of bloody and
criminal organizations in Mexico you had
a lot of people who were trained as
Special Forces not just military Special
Forces trained some of them were trained
in West Point in one of the most elite
academies for the military in the US and
they were just when they went back to
work in Mexico in the army they were
just getting [ __ ] loads of money more
sorry much more money from from the drug
trafficking organization than from the
institutions in the country but he who's
more at fault
he's whose is it the setter chopping off
someone head or killing someone I was
mutilating someone alive or he said the
the policies are the big entities who
would know that all of that is happen
and not doing anything about it and
there's a historical death from Mexican
politicians there's a historical debt
from US politicians the drug on war I
think it's just got holes everywhere
frankly on all of those and what is the
situation in Mexico at the moment so for
instance I read about to you that wadis
yeah and that just seems to be a water
there doesn't seem to be any law there
happening whatsoever if you're a woman
it's a dreadful place to be but it seems
to be even worse for it for a woman in
terms of kidnapping sexual violence how
bad all things in Mexico at the moment
or does it depend whereabouts you live
historic how bad things are anything in
in the in the northern parts of Mexico
we're talking about Juarez is on the
northwest very near the California and
then you go all the way to the other
side which is called some early purse
which is in between Mexico Texas and
Mexico anything around the border
between Mexico and the US are they're
all drug trafficking routes and they I
think it's probably fair to say all of
that is pretty lawless and not because
of a lack of police police are there but
there's just huge doubts and that's the
best way of saying it so all of that is
yeah no one's been really in control
apart from the cartel
you decide what the hell's going on but
that's not just that it's then you've
got areas like a capital Co on the
Pacific Coast all of that is a big stake
called Guerrero there that is run by a
cartel called the Mitchell County cartel
and then you've got the order area of
New Flyer little government or Cancun
which is called Veracruz again that's
another place which is you know
incredibly filled with a lot of criminal
activity historically in Mexico Mexico
City has always been this bubble where
all the drug leaders live nothing
happens and that's probably still the
case I think Mexico in general in the
last year at least it saw a huge rise in
murder rates and this is not just drug
cartel people killing each other this is
the the increase or the size of a
criminal activity that leads to for
instance a kidnapping industry in Mexico
is huge and a lot of these people act in
coordination either with authorities or
with the cartels themselves and that's
when like real civilians are start
suffering when you get a huge growth in
a kidnapping industry that's just
effectively kidnapping the lady who runs
a laundromats in Mexico City if I did
some stuff some years ago about the
kidnapping industry people would be in
kidnap for $100 like just I'm being
brutalized and then being called over
the phone can just give me a hundred
dollars like what you've gone through
all of that just to give me and just
doesn't make sense the kidnapping
industry is a huge is the humanitarian
effect of the drug war ii know i was
going to say and going back to trump and
the wall is that where you think a lot
of popularity comes from where he's
saying you know we're gonna build this
wall we're gonna isolate mexico or is it
does popularity come from somewhere else
the wool is a thimble really isn't it
the wall is a symbol of this way we'll
stop it and sorry I'm just laughing
forget you can build a world that the
drug is going through tunnels you do
that and in the east of Mexico so a lot
of stuff I'm just gonna widen out a bit
Mexico imports a lot of cheap goods from
China and then sends that to the US
that's one of the NAFTA trade deals and
agreement and there's a huge economy
around that and we're talking about
thousands of lorries going every week up
from Mexico
to the US well guess what's in those
lorries as well there's a lot of drugs
in there as well just to put the
counterpoint on the wall I mean but no
but think about it imagine you live in
in the south of the United States and
across the border from you is this
lawless place where people are being
kidnapped for ransom of $100 people
haven't their heads chopped off tortured
guns all this violence you'd want to
protect yourself and your family from
from that wouldn't you I mean so and
that that I imagine why a lot of
Americans filled a wall while a symbol
is necessary or border security is
necessary right yes but the a problem as
a result of the flows of immigration and
drug trafficking in that region is a lot
of immigrants who we see there any
migrant caravans for instance or people
going from Central America or all parts
of the world go through Mexico to the US
there's a huge sort of people
trafficking business around it run by
the drug cartels again a lot of those
people are kept in safe houses and
called for ransom for their relatives in
Central America or wherever they're
coming from a lot of those safe houses
are in the US so there's no wall to stop
you from that the criminal activity is
going on there well there well the
history tells you recent history tells
you is that a lot of the violence
doesn't go into the u.s. because yeah
probably the legal system the judicial
system just works much better than law
enforcement ages it just works much
better but that the Wolves not going to
stop the presence of all of that
happening and yeah you're not gonna see
a turf war between drug cartels and on
the other side of the wall that the
criminal activity is going to be there
around the corner
and in what you're saying effective is
that there is no way of stopping the
flow of drugs going into the United
States and there's people show their
mouths
I don't consume it anymore right yeah
well that doesn't look like it's going
to happen so this is this is where we
come back to you know the the
decriminalization of drugs because if
you take like from some estimates in
some of these northern states and Mexico
is like seventy to eighty percent of the
whole economy of the state is related to
Jakarta drivers it's just that that
means like eight out of every ten
dollars that's spent in
in there is spent because of drunk right
or by the cartels so these are places
that are completely taken over there is
no government there is no police there
is no structure at all and the only way
that's possible is that our money
essentially Western money's going in
there into the pockets of these drug
cartels so if you if you stop that money
from going into the hands of illegal
criminals and people like that and you
create a situation where drugs are legal
and there's no incentive that a lot of
people would say that is a way that you
tackle the problem on both ends here in
the West you decriminalize drug use and
therefore you end up with great parties
whatever I try to make a serious point
your [ __ ] roommate
so Portugal had a huge heroin addiction
problem yeah and some 10 years ago what
they did they just legalized it right
and what they did is that people who are
addicts to it now go to a clinic a
private clinic a private or government
claim I'm not sure the detail there but
they go and get their fix yeah that
doesn't kill them there's no health
implications of any of its controlled
and managed you don't go you don't get
cleaned yeah but there's not a business
of opium on the streets yeah and that I
I've seen some studies and I've read
them about how that has reduced
significantly the amount of criminal
activity around drug use how many people
are here in the UK have had their doors
barge down because someone's going crazy
needs a fix he's just looking for quick
money anywhere right you see a lot of
drug addicts in the UK I'm talking more
about heroin radix probably who are just
looking for quick money anywhere to try
to get a fix
well Portugal sort of tried to do that
we're all right I'll give it to you but
chill we'll give it to you in a managed
way you don't have to go and steal some
money for that that's a smaller problem
than huge millions of tons of cocaine
marijuana and heroin everywhere but then
you have another country in South
America which is your away which
legalized cannabis like three years ago
they allow people to grow it for a
personal consumption and that
effectively led to petty crime on the
streets reduce and massively because
there was no incentive for anyone to be
just dealing drugs and protect in my
corner that makes so much sense to me
yeah it makes complete sense I'm gonna
put the counterpoint no so we had Peter
Hitchens on a couple of weeks ago and
Peter when it came to the war on drugs
he's very much in favor of you know
being incredibly harsh on people who
deal drugs really clamping down making
you know you know making the penalties
incredibly severe why does that not work
do you think because it's not as simple
as its we've had a war on drugs
well is it Nixon when we're talking
about I wasn't even life was sixties I
mean I think it had its run some work
why does it not work because you're
trying to clamp down on the security
side of things but then to deal with the
problem let's deal with our chapel right
where he comes from this estate called
Sinaloa in the hills all these farmers
thirty years ago they would just produce
and let's imagine battle yeah
strawberries whatever yeah one day they
thought okay look at this if I do
cannabis I'm gonna get a hundred times
or what I'm getting for strawberries
yeah what happens all those farmers are
now producing cannabis oh right okay
I'll kill those chap on all this mate
what do I do with all those farmers then
yeah yeah well you're gonna kill them
then well there are no policies so
shooting down and executing all the drug
cartel leaders in the world doesn't
change the fact that you have a huge
economy that has gone all the way to
producing drugs rather than producing
things that are not drugs so there
aren't it has to be accompanied by
government policy on - I'm going to give
you an incentive to not to produce drugs
and to get your kids to school and to
produce something that will actually
allow yourself an income I'm guy there's
a cultural change as well why me farmer
in Sinaloa producing opium and getting
my SUV bought tomorrow was my incentive
for me to then right let me scale down
and this is what I should afford this is
what I need but I have water running
water I schools work I've got all the
needs I have and I said okay I'll go
back to doing strawberries war the
violence policy on let's crack down on
everyone doesn't work on it yeah
actually makes things worse because when
you're on
move the head of a classical thing
that's where all these wars come from
because you've got ten little people now
competing for that table dogs bottom up
and they become more brutal and more
violent because the struggle for you
know there's an opportunity to make a
living day in a country where it is very
difficult to do that and then the other
thing about good good the Gideon bodies
of the drug war or it's not that clear
right let's kill all the let's get rid
of all the choppers put them all in jail
Shaw what about the government side of
things well yeah all those people
allowed that that war on drug is not
going on them that war on drugs if
you're going to do it that way should
need to get rid of a lot of other people
as well I'm not cartel leaders so the
president so essentially if you were in
charge you would say legalize it what
would you legalize would you legalize
cocaine or marijuana lieutenant Francis
yeah I don't know I I think all of that
yeah that sounds in a simplistic way
yeah I think I'll go down and out that
route but it needs a lot of work into
what do you allow people to have and
what sort of structures do you do you
let people you know I suppose if you
legalize all of that there will be that
inevitably that stuff about ever is it
going to be a huge binge and then how do
you deal with a fallout of that whether
that's Portugal or some of the United
States states that have legalized that I
don't think anyone for legalize cocaine
oh that's a really tricky one it's much
more I think cannabis of course kind of
is much more socially acceptable than
all the others but again it will have
its its its health indications to deal
with but that's probably more manageable
cocaine it's probably much more rougher
one do we need to even be consuming
cocaine but if you look at prohibition
of alcohol in the 50s or forties maybe
whiskey was the cocaine at the time when
people are now drinking whiskey anyway
they learned how to do it maybe we as a
society need to just learn how to deal
with that I don't know it's it's a I
think it needs a lot of health
monitoring and sort of awareness etc etc
it may lead to a bench what do we do
with that all right it doesn't lead to a
bench great
we have a backup option here to help
people to cope with that but I feel
we're in dreamland here that's yes the
theme like the world we live that is why
do you think that is because it I I
don't know maybe it's me but to me all
of the stuff we're talking about is
common sense
like anyone who's looked into it knows
old stuff we know about Portugal we know
about Switzerland we know about as I
said you know North America as well it's
obvious and we could be preventing tens
of thousands of people of being killed
in Mexico and all of this suffering and
misery and yeah it's almost like taboo
to discuss it in this country in some in
in politics certainly talk to
politicians they won't touch it with a
barge pole
I think the noncentral view would be
that people need to get elected on the
loo wherever they need to be elected
that's a nonsense nonsense
I think the cynical view is a probably I
think I would be surprised if the amount
of people in bed with the drug
trafficking business is so big that it's
just they can't scale back from it we
ready well even in the way you reckon
there's politicians in this country who
who are influenced by that nope it would
explain a performance for breaks
awareness drug producing countries where
where does the drug trafficking line
stop and then the politicians line goes
in look Pablo Escobar was a become this
mythical figure and a lot of his bad
side has been sort of washed away in
Netflix Pablo Escobar has is still being
remembered as one of the biggest drug
cartel leaders ever have it who have
ever existed the drug traffic of missus
in Colombia is like a hundred times
bigger than when Pablo Escobar about
that why is that no that's still there
that's happening a lot of politicians
are still aware of that the drug war is
the US had funded military operations
there as funds helicopters all sorts of
stuff
the business just grew I think there's a
lot of accountability to be had on the
government policy and official side of
things the more you dig the more the
stuff you read like legit stuff I'm not
talking about conspiracy theory here
yeah
it's it's not good and I think that's
probably why well I guess in those
countries it's probably impossible to be
a politician if you're not in league
with these people because otherwise
they'll kill you or you'll never be a
problem and how many politicians have
died because of that so again we in
dreamland yeah sure we can definitely
think that legalization should be one of
those ways there are there's a former
leader of the Mexican government old man
called Vicente Fox who who is drive
banging that drum pretty loudly right
now about trying to legalize stuff will
he get that through who knows I mean
they'll be amazing if in 20 years time
drugs are legalized I mean I think you
get rid of a lot of the problems that
you have but if anyone has watched the
wire follow the bodies you're gonna find
them if you follow the money yeah you're
not gonna get you're not gonna find them
you're not gonna like what you find them
yeah that's very true
but that's why I think we need which is
great to have you on to have this
conversation because I think I don't
think when we talk about legalization in
this country we think about the bodies
in Mexico I don't think we think about
the fact that these countries have
become lawless places hmm
where all of this where people are being
kidnapped for $100 because of the drugs
mmm directly it's not and you know I
think if we put it if we contextualize
in that way it becomes a much easier
case to make I think and I think it's an
important conversation we're almost out
of time Lima thank you so much for
coming on all right we've got one
question for you oh the question we
always ask is what is the one thing that
people need to be talking about but
aren't speaking about the moment talking
about at the moment in general yeah it
could be anything at all anything at all
I would say that people need to really
look at what's going on in Venezuela in
terms of a humanitarian catastrophe I
think you see bits and pieces of it but
I don't think the world has paid enough
attention to it and now saying is one of
the worse crisis I think I think this is
something that's not going to age well
for a lot of people when you go and look
back five years and say [ __ ] we didn't
look at that that was an important thing
that no one was paying attention to
millions of people have left people are
struggling to feed it's a it's a society
in collapse and it's got one of the
biggest oil reserves in the world I
think it's a it's something completely
underreported everywhere
so what just I said one more question
but out of that I didn't want to end on
maybe something that people can do if
your what if someone's watching this
discussion and going well this is
terrible
is there anything I can do is a can I go
and Lobby my politician to do this or
can I soak to Jeremy Corbyn we made of
is there anything that we can do as
individuals is there a particular
charity that is doing good work you feel
in Venezuela people can give money to is
a is is there's only a particular policy
that you think needs to be advocated and
supported I think you can do all of that
yeah but from here please stop looking
at this as if this is a failure of
socialism of not just I think that would
help massively and create awareness on
an issue that is just being sucked into
if I criticizes and I love Colby and
then I can be able to because I'm
criticizing socialism this is not about
socialism it's not about capitalism and
that rhetoric is the pressure that is
helping politicians not do anything
about it if you're talking about whether
this works or doesn't work or I don't
criticize any left-wing government in
the world this is not a this is not a
left or right wing problem this is
something that's gone wrong and people
need to call it out well thank you very
much for coming on trigonometry wait a
minute all right for anyone who wants to
follow you on Twitter to keep up with
the great work that you're doing what's
your Twitter handle very simple it's ad
Vlad underscore Hernandez underscore so
father Vladimir as always follow us at
trigger pod on all the social media
subscribe to the YouTube channel click
that Bell button next to subscribe
button to make sure you get notified
when a video comes out give us an iTunes
review and remember we have a podcast so
it's not just a video you can listen to
us as you're driving taking the train
whatever is your doing we have that on
iTunes it's on SoundCloud with surely
migrating as well from there and yeah
we'll see you in a week from now and
also guys please just check to see that
you haven't been on subscribed on
YouTube on you Tunes on this is to deal
with
anyway on YouTube just check if you have
been um subscribed please subscribe
again but let us know as well because we
want to know yeah absolutely and yep
thank you very much and see you next
week
in a week
[Music]